today we give you three tips
to improve your English in a little
time the first tip which is easy
to do is to watch your series
and films in English but with
subtitles in French and once
you are  at ease you can put the
subtitles in English and finally you can
remove them completely the second
tip is to listen to the
English music, look at the lyrics and
deduce the French translation
after which you can check your ideas and
like this you will assimilate a lot of
vocabulary the third tip of course
is to join the little scan alone
to learn English in a
fun and fun way subscribe for more
tips to improve your English and
go to  the
British candle website for more information
on our